[Music]
more on the prime minister and the
chancellor in just a moment i'm sure the
chancellor will be interested in this
story breaking news on inflation and a
bigger rise than we were expecting today
figures just in paul kelso stanley bye
for us our business correspondent of
course uh hi paul tell us more
yeah good morning chancellor still in
office the headache for the occupier of
that office growing inflation in the
year to march 2022 has risen to 7
that's up 0.8
on the figure in march it's ahead of
most expectations it's also ahead of
where the bank of england forecasts they
thought inflation would be around now
it's on course heading towards a
predicted peak above eight percent later
in the year these figures are for march
they include of course the period in the
invasion of ukraine by russia and fuel
prices are the biggest single
contributor to this transport costs have
gone up over one percent in the month
month so that immediate impact on diesel
and petrol prices that we saw following
the invasion has fed straight through
into the goods across the economy
inflation now seven percent
wow thank you paul i know we'll chat
about that throughout the course of the
show thank you
main story this morning i'm sorry but
i'm staying the message from the prime
minister who's standing firm amid calls
to quit after being fined for breaking
his own lockdown rules the question now
is will he face further fines for five
more events he's been linked to his
chancellor too receiving a fine let's
take a look back at the timeline of
events for the events linked to boris
johnson specifically the prime minister
has been fined for his birthday
celebration on the 19th of june 2020
where it's claimed that up to 30 people
attended a party with cake in the
cabinet room the previous month and on
the 20th of may about 100 staff from
number 10 were invited to a bring your
own booze event in the dining street
garden on the 13th of november mr
johnson gave a speech at the leaving do
for his director of communications on
the same day it's also alleged that
carrie johnson hosted a party
in the number 10 flat it's claimed there
was a christmas quiz at number 10 on the
15th of december the pm insists it was
virtual this event is not being
investigated by the police
and two days later on the 17th of
december it's believed mr johnson
attended another event for a number 10
official uh on the fourth i've received
a
fixed penalty notice from the
metropolitan police relating to an event
in downing street on the 19th of june
2020 and let me say immediately that
i've paid the fine and i once again
offer a full
apology at that time
it did not occur to me
that this might have been a breach of
the rules but of course the police have
found otherwise and i
fully respect the outcome
of their investigation
i understand the anger that many will
feel that i myself fell short when it
came to observing the very rules which
the government i lead had introduced to
protect the public
short straw this morning falls to
transport secretary grant shouts mr
schaps thank you so much for taking the
time to join us we know it's going to be
a challenging morning for you but we
appreciate you taking the time uh at
least 50 fixed penalty notices issued so
far potentially more to come it appears
that downing street has one of the
highest crime rates in the country this
morning the pm has presided over that
how can he possibly remain in
office good morning okay well look first
of all i um i know the the prime
minister has apologized for this you
just heard him say he accepts
responsibility and he's reorganized
number ten but you know i for one um as
somebody who couldn't see my own dad for
four months during this uh period um
during lockdowns whilst he was in
hospital
and we didn't know that we'd see him
again
completely understand the upset and
anger that this causes because i feel it
myself
and um the one thing i know and i spoke
to the uh the prime minister uh is he is
completely mortified um by
uh this happening uh and we know now a
lot more about the day itself as well
because uh
we understand about the meetings that
were going on eight separate meetings
that day before the prime minister went
out and visited a school and came back
and uh and uh by surprise
some of his team had uh
arranged to wish him happy birthday it
shouldn't have happened he's paid the 50
quid fine that's the right thing to to
do he's reorganized number 10 and i
think he's got a big job to do
uh particularly with
the cost of living inflation those
pressures and of course all of that
coming about because of the the war in
ukraine and i think he's shown terrific
leadership with regard to the west's
response to that war
so far he's presided over 50 separate
rule breaks at downing street including
that of his wife
and his chancellor likely that more rule
breaks will be recognised by the police
to come another five events that he
reportedly attended how can he possibly
remain in office
well look at that and everyone is is
human people sometimes make mistakes he
wasn't there for the 50 events that
you're referring to of course and many
times he was wasn't even in the in the
building um uh he's human and humans are
and sometimes they make mistakes okay
and
and and and that's what happened here
it's been a very high profile job and
quite rightly uh the police have uh
investigated
independently come to their their view
he's apologized he's accepted
responsibility he's paid the 50 quid uh
fine um the question i suppose your
question goes to the heart of uh you
know did he set out to do this was it
something that was done with with malice
with intent and the answer of course is
is is no it's something that happened uh
in error uh and uh
as i said i've spoken to him he's
incredibly embarrassed by the whole
thing he he he knows that it was stupid
and defensible um but
he didn't set out to break the law uh
and he's paid the fixed penalty notice
uh fine uh and has a very big job to to
to do
i accept somebody in the round ignorance
is no defense in law is it
that's right okay but you know as you
know so occasionally people bird on the
wrong side of the law during lockdown
and uh you know he has uh quite rightly
paid the price 50 quid in in this case
and and of course reputational uh damage
but um
the question who should be responsible
for the goings-on in dining street when
on at least
50 separate occasions the law was broken
even not the prime minister
well even when the prime minister wasn't
there he's already said he takes full
responsibility
and the law was broken and
and this was um as you can see this is
two years ago this particular incident
and um you know since then he's
completely reformed number 10 being very
large changes as you know in and
personnel but look i i don't i i don't
think there's any is that i
personally
when i heard about these goings on was
very upset i didn't think i'd see my dad
again you know i think that a lot of
people in the country would have felt
the the same way about it it absolutely
shouldn't happen it's
incredibly serious and quite rightly uh
that's been recognized and fines being
paid who's responsible mr shap who's
responsible for at least 50 rule breaks
law breaks at downing street
obviously individuals who who not the
prime minister he doesn't have overall
responsibility
of course he does
okay so he's responsible for 50 times
the law being broken in downing street
and yet he still remains was he's
honored many of those times he won't
have been there but nonetheless he says
himself he takes over responsibility and
i think that's absolutely the right
thing for him to do yeah it's the first
time that a prime minister has broken
the law in the history of the office
more than 300 years since robert walpole
took office he's brought the role into
disrepute was his honor
well as i as i've said i think he in
accepting and apologizing and paying the
fine and reforming number 10 and getting
on with the job including in ukraine uh
being uh one of perhaps the uh most uh
proactive we're talking about
if we may please mr we're not talking
about ukraine we're talking specifically
about partygate this morning let's stay
on topic you're talking about p
reforming dining street five people have
resigned 45 separate breaches so
allegra stratton's gone done rosenfeld's
gone martin reynolds have gone jack
doyle's gone kate joseph's gone 45 other
breaches who's responsible for those you
say that he's reformed downing street
only five people have gone 50 breaches
that's clearly not true because there
are a number of other people who haven't
mentioned have gone including dominic
cummings uh lee kay
and many others are you saying that
dominick comics broke the rules
i i look i'm not i'm not getting into
specifics of anybody well you just did
saying there's more than five but i'm
simply saying hey there's more than five
people who've gone the most important
thing is is not just it's not just about
who's come and gone it's also about the
fact he's now set up an office of the
prime minister to specifically look
after the way that the uh the operation
of number 10 uh works and and you know i
think it's worth understanding uh the in
number 10 the prime minister who leads a
particularly busy uh diary of course
goes from one meeting to the next to the
next that doesn't matter
it doesn't matter well let me it doesn't
matter
57 no let me just put it to you 50
separate occasions so far
that had the law has been broken in
downing street the prime minister set
the law the prime minister broke the law
the prime minister misled parliament
where's his
honor no okay by the same logic anybody
who broke a lockdown law wouldn't be in
their job would they the point of this
is that the prime minister
lying when we've made a mistake
continually lying when we've made a
mistake blaming others and not accepting
responsibility we know that people have
done that in the past is not a good look
for a politician for a public servant
especially the prime minister where's
his honor
so it's not a good look for anyone but
he has not done that what he's done is
accepted for responsibility you keep
asking the same question
i've answered it absolutely but i can't
do it unless you let me get a word in uh
i want to absolutely answer it the
simple answer is he takes full
responsibility for all those breaches
whether he was there or in the vast vast
majority exactly
and so on 50 separate occasions the law
was broken
and there will be more to come
we are told or certainly led to believe
by the police including five separate
events that the prime minister attended
this is just one event that he's been
fined for that his wife and his
chancellor were at five other events as
well i could go through them if you want
i'm sure you're aware of them if he
receives more time
if he receives more fines and he then
subsequently quite obviously misled
parliament both on the 1st of december
and the 8th of december when he was at
the dispatch box he should go where is
his honor
i look i i appreciate that what you're
doing is listing everything that you can
uh that you've got to list there but i
would prefer that we leave this to the
police i think they're the right people
to uh come to conclusions on that
they've decided he broke the law what
they have to say they've decided and
he's apologized and he's accepted
responsibility and he's reformed number
10 and he's getting on with um doing the
job and as i say i completely get what
you're saying okay because i've been in
the position myself of not being able to
see uh my own family uh under these
circumstances i find it i'm very annoyed
by it i find it you know angers me
greatly i've spoken to the prime
minister he's mortified but just to be
absolutely clear i think motive is very
important in the situation like this
he didn't go out uh to with mattis to go
and uh break the law he was very very he
had a blatant disregard
he made the laws and he had a blatant
disregard for them
20th of may bring your own booze party
19th of june he's already been fined for
13th of november party after dominic
cummings and lee kane quit 15th of
december christmas quiz attended by the
pm where there was booze and tinsel 17th
of december two uh events there 14th of
january leaving drinks the pm allegedly
attended you know that's not just all he
made a mistake that's six separate
occasions the law that he made he was
the policy maker he broke the law he
then went to parliament and said don't
know what you're talking about it must
have been them it's not me he was lying
he was hiding behind other people they
fell on their sword and he continues to
say that he's going to stay in office
where is his honor
you just listed a whole bunch of events
uh in which the police have not in fact
ruled uh as yet not yet didn't knowingly
he didn't so if they rule against him
with those other five events will he go
then
okay
he didn't knowingly um break the law
didn't do it deliberately he didn't come
to parliament and and uh having
knowingly done this he he thought in
fact uh the the same people who uh
wished him happy birthday he'd already
been meeting with
earlier that day uh was not breaking the
law if the police take a different view
he absolutely accepts that and has paid
the fine i see what you're doing which
is to sort of list everything else that
you've read in the in the newspapers are
reported i think it's fair to allow the
police to take a look at that rather
than uh jump to all of those okay so
let's follow that through then should we
what will it take for the pm to leave
office will it be more fines will that
be the stage where he has to accept that
he's not an honorable man
well look i don't agree okay we live in
a democracy and people have every right
to
vote to
decide what happens with their
representatives uh i think a lot of
people take the view that
went wrong here
i i think helpful if i can just get one
answer out i think a lot of people take
the view that although this clearly went
wrong it's very serious i don't uh i
don't seek to minimize it in any way
shape or form not least because i feel
pretty aggrieved about things like
myself given not being able to see my
own family
most people look at this understand that
we're talking about an event nearly two
years ago that apologized his accepted
responsibility his reform number 10 and
although you don't want to talk about
this either that he's getting on and
helping to lead the western's response
west's response because that's not the
topic of discussion this morning if
you'll forgive me i'm leading the
interview mr shaps and let me say
if i may if i may i wanted to respond to
your suggestion that it's a democracy 75
of the public
75
of the public feel that he continually
and deliberately lied how can he
remain in office as an honorable man i'm
guessing from what you're saying you
think he is an honorable man
i do and
the last part of the point that i was
trying to answer is relevant here even
though you keep telling me it's not
people judge somebody in the round they
judge how they do their job overall i'm
not saying that the prime minister uh
isn't a flawed individual we're all
flawed different ways we all uh the
question is did somebody set out to do
these things with malice and actually
overall is he doing a good job as prime
minister which is why i do think it's
relevant how he performs the rest of his
job the rest of his uh task uh and uh
and and he made a mistake it was
embarrassing and and stupid the prime
minister's mortified uh about it but i
think there's a big job for him to get
on and and do uh on behalf of the
british people on behalf of the uh the
world fighting this this this cruel uh
walk and and that is why i judge him in
the round and you know okay you say you
judge him in the round but absolutely
and i must let you go in a second
because we're running out of time you
say he judged him in the round he's
already been sacked twice for lying um
he
slurred um hillsborough fans suggesting
that they were partially drunken fans
were partially responsible for what
happened in 1989. he was failing to be
completely transparent about the downing
street flat charging 840 pounds a roll
for wallpaper when people can't put food
in their kids bellies and and then he
allegedly uh promised a business
interest for jennifer r curie who was
his alleged lover let's judge him in the
round
he
helped to make sure that this country
received vaccines before any other
country in the world got the roll out
and the booster done got us out of
lockdown before anyone else gave us the
fastest growing economy in the g7 last
year and as well leading the world's
response uh to uh president putin
according to president zielenski i take
somebody in the round okay and i think
that this prime minister has much more
to give and that is why despite the fact
that i think what happened was wrong uh
he has apologized his accepted
responsibility he's paid his 50 quid
fine
and he's getting on
with his very important job running the
country
transport secretary thank you
let's have a look what the papers think
people have a right to expect better
that's the telegraph quoting mr johnson
himself from his latest apology he has
however again refused to resign
the eye reminds us that it may not be
over yet as far as the fines are
concerned and reports that 57 percent of
people want the prime minister to resign
don't they know there's a war on the
mail asks attacking what it calls the
left howling for resignations when there
are more important things to consider
the express says the prime minister has
promised to do better for britain in the
future
the star's view is clear depicting both
mr johnson and mr sunak as pinocchio
complete with long noses
but the matter is far from over the
police are still investigating a number
of other gatherings in and around
downing street madeline has gone down to
scotland yard for us this morning and
good morning to you maddie uh we're
hearing there from the transport
secretary we need to allow the police to
do their job it continues
good morning kate it does continue it's
50 fines and counting because we know
there are 12 um events parties that the
metropolitan police are investigating
and we've only had um a couple of the
outcomes the fines um uh issued so far
so that's 30 we think from the prime
minister's birthday party in june 2020
where the prime minister's wife carrie
johnson presented him with a cake so
they they are now three of those fines
um including the prime minister and his
chancellor bryce johnson but and that
makes him the first prime minister to
have been found to have broken the law
in office and what's shocking is it may
not be the only time because we think
the prime minister was involved in six
of those 12 um parties being
investigated including the infamous
bring your own booze garden party
in may 2020 which the prime minister was
pictured um attending and that sent
seemed to be a more clear-cut example of
the rules the lockdown rules being
broken so
certainly uh already one fine but he
could very well face more fines as that
mets investigations continue
okay thank you thanks a lot maddie
later in the show the prime minister's
former press secretary will walden will
join us discuss boris johnson's party
gate fine
and still to come we'll be speaking to
the smp leader as well in westminster
ian blackford who's calling for boris
johnson to quit in the wake of the
partygate fines
we'll be speaking to the eu ambassador
to ukraine about what more the eu can do
to help the country in its hour of need
and also speaking to the former pensions
minister and that's baroness altman on
the partygate lines
u.s president joe biden describing
vladimir putin's actions in ukraine as
genocide yesterday it was claimed that
the russian army may have used chemical
agents in mariopol ukrainian fighters
released footage of people alleged to
have been affected which caused victims
to briefly pass out
what we have right now just the unusual
symptoms yeah of unknown substance yeah
and thank god the people were exposed to
these substances
yes i called it genocide because it
become clear and clear
that putin is just trying to wipe out
the idea of even being able to pee
ukrainian
and the amount the evidence is mounting
it's different than it was last week the
more evidence is coming out of the
literally the horrible things
that the russians have done in ukraine
and we're going to only learn more and
more about the devastation
and
we'll let the lawyers decide
internationally whether or not it
qualifies but it sure seems that way to
me
today new aerial pictures have emerged
which appear to show a buildup of
russian troops and equipment heading to
the donbass area ukraine says it's
expecting a renewed assault on the
region in the next few days
jason standing by for us in southern
ukraine nikolayev to be precise uh this
morning hi jason good morning to you
genocide is what president biden says
yeah that's right i mean he's been uh
looking at the evidence of what's been
coming out of some of the horrific
images obviously we've seen some of the
northern
suburbs around kiev and that's what his
conclusion is and i think the worry now
for the u.s and again intelligence
sources there
saying that they're expecting this push
to come this week
and the satellite images that we've seen
in western russia of those troops
massing dozens of vehicles tanks support
vehicles troops tents supplies they're
clearly gearing up in the west of russia
to move into the dombass and the
satellite images as well in the donbass
of around a convoy of around about 200
vehicles heading through there that's
where the main thrust of this
new push this new phase is going to
happen there's no doubt about that
the question is how successful it will
be will it will it then push up to
places like kharkiv
and possibly
along the southern coast as well
obviously we've seen what's happened in
maripol
bombings there again continuing this
morning
but will they push further along to
places like mikolai of here there has
been activity in milk alive here even
this morning some of the villages we're
told there were attacks there but they
have been repelled so we're just now
waiting really for this onslaught to
begin okay thank you jason
the mayor of new york has called for a
change in the u.s gun laws after a
subway shooting which left 10 people
injured the attack began as a train
pulled into the station causing panic on
the platform smoke billowed from one of
the carriages and commuters desperately
tried to escape the gunfire
some passengers braved the danger
tending to the wounded where they'd
fallen first responders arrived to a
chaotic scene multiple casualties and a
gunman at large
police identified 62 year old frank
james as a person of interest and
offered a 50 000 reward for information
they said a gun they found had been
fired 33 times
more misery for people hoping to travel
from dover over easter piano ferries the
company which unlawfully sacked 800
workers without notice last month had
hoped to resume crossings between dover
and calais on good friday but it's
confirmed that it's the ship the spirit
of britain which has failed a number of
key safety tests and was declared not
fit to be cleared for sea
a judge has praised the commitment of
insulate britain protesters who
disrupted the journeys of thousands of
people on the m25 by sitting across one
of the busiest junctions the judge
stephen leakes said the 12 activists had
inspired him to reduce his own
environmental impact but he fined them
hundreds of pounds saying he had to
apply the law
and after more than two years of strict
covet isolation new zealand is reopening
its international borders it's a stage
process today it's open to vaccinated
australians but from next month people
from the uk and the united states will
also be able to visit
nicole is uh in wellington for us we put
her on a plane and there she is hi
nicole how was it
well it's certainly been a long haul for
new zealand to get here as you said it's
been closed for over two years not only
to all international travelers but it's
been incredibly difficult for even
people from new zealand to return home
and they've really only been able to do
that in the last few weeks without a
full hotel quarantine
but now new zealand is opening up to the
rest of the world starting with
australians who are able to enter and
from next month
uh people from the uk from the u.s and
other european countries will be able to
come here as well
australia's covert night not australia
new zealand's covert 19 strategy has
been this go early go hard policy and it
managed to succeed for quite a long time
they beat covert 19 twice they had for a
long time barely any deaths very few
lockdowns they were considered the gold
standard the envy of the world but even
new zealand
could not defeat omicron when it hit the
shores and now they are getting around
10 000 cases a day they've had over 500
deaths and they've decided that it's
time to open up
a number of flights are starting to
arrive we've got a bit of a lull here at
the moment you can see there has been a
welcoming committee arranged to try and
greet australians and new zealanders who
are coming home also that's the prime
minister jacinda ardern there right
behind me she's about to give a media
interview and she's come here also to
greet people and to try to say that new
zealand's shores are open but it's still
being a controversial
uh controversial policy here
sorry yeah i wonder if you could nicole
can you just i mean she's not yet
started tell her you're live and see if
she wants to have a quick chat with us
go on i dare you okay all right let's
try that
uh jacinda would you like to speak with
sky news at all
afterwards
afterwards we'd love to hear you in the
uk
okay all right well hopefully she will
afterwards so
uh okay hopefully we can bring jacinda
arjun
uh for a conversation with sky news
uh but yeah it's been a controversial
policy here in new zealand uh we've had
a number of big protests in february we
saw people out on the streets in cities
across the country
fed up with uh all these covert
restrictions okay nicole thank you
now it's one of hollywood's bitterest
battles actors johnny depp and amber
heard will be in court again today in
what lawyers call a mudslinging soap
opera mr depp is suing his ex-wife for
50 million dollars after she accused him
of domestic violence during their
marriage but she is counter suing him
for a hundred million dollars martha
kellner has more
a courthouse in virginia one of
hollywood's ugliest and most enduring
legal battles is rolling into town
behind the curtain actor amber heard
travelling to another court date with
her ex-husband one of film's biggest
stars
mr depp
how are you feeling
he may be feeling buoyant for now but
bruising weeks in court await mr depp
he is suing over this article written by
ms heard in which she recounts her
experience as a survivor she says of
sexual violence
johnny depp isn't mentioned by name but
he says it's plainly about him his
lawyer explaining why he's seeking 50
million dollars in damages
for nearly 30 years
mr depp built a reputation as one of the
most talented actors in hollywood today
his name is associated with a lie a
false statement uttered by his former
wife
the defendant amber heard
that falsely cast mr depp
falsely unfairly
characterized
cast mr depp as a villain
ms heard in turn is counter suing for
100 million dollars she says she was
physically emotionally and sexually
abused during their tumultuous
relationship
it takes eight to ten tablets of ecstasy
almost immediately and the next three
days are just a cycle of of a very very
very violent uh uh activity by him
he rips off her nightgown he has her
jammed up against a bar he has hurled
bottles and bottles at her she has
dragged her across the floor on the
broken bottles and the liquor
you may have a sense of deja vu and
that's because what we've heard today
and what we'll hear for the next seven
weeks is very familiar it's similar to a
court case in london in 2020 in which
johnny depp was suing the sun newspaper
for libel he lost that case the judge
deciding that there was enough evidence
to support their description of him as a
wife beater
this trial is the sequel another attempt
at reputation damage limitation and
despite more grisly details of his
private life many of depp's fans are
standing by him martha calmer sky news
virginia
now the uh you're very welcome to join
us on the breakfast show here on sky
news this morning the transport
secretary did grant shaps uh he's been
defending the prime minister on the
accusations that he presided over at
least 50 separate breaks of the law
in downing street amongst other things
this is what mr schapps had to say this
morning
57 no let me just put it to you 50
separate occasions so far
that had the law has been broken in
downing street the prime minister set
the law the prime minister broke the law
the prime minister misled parliament
where's his honor what he's done is
accepted full responsibility you keep
asking the same question
absolutely but i can't do unless you let
me get a word in uh i want to absolutely
answer it the simple answer is he takes
full responsibility for all those
breaches
is the eu likely to allow ukraine to
join the union the european union
president zelensky has applied for a
fast-track membership but the eu
enlargement process is very slow moving
taking years rather than months so let's
speak to the eu ambassador to ukraine
and that's mati masakis hello to you
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning could um joining
the eu be fast-tracked for the ukraine
good morning
indeed the
ukraine's
eu path has started
and it has started with an unprecedented
speed
uh what is normally been done in
[Music]
two years or over two years period
is now uh attempted uh within three
months
namely namely the first assessment by
the
by the european commission
of ukraine's compliance with the
basic criteria for membership namely
namely working democracy and working
market
economy
and we
we expect or that's the working
assumption to hear
more in june
what more in the meantime can the eu do
the countries of the eu to help ukraine
to step up what we are doing sending
weapons
it was very clear what the chief of uh
eu's foreign policy jose barrel said
after he is and president on the lion's
visit to to kiev
last week
we need to help ukraine
to prevail on the battlefield
and and the eu is doing that providing
exactly the weapons that
that ukrainians
are requesting
the eu is providing
massive humanitarian assistance
and the eu has repurposed its
all projects and programs in ukraine a
yearly worth of
at least 200 million to strengthen
ukraine's resilience
do you know anything more about these
suggestions that we were hearing
yesterday about chemical weapons attacks
in ukraine do you have any further
information on that
this information is not confirmed
we of course
are all reading the reports
um president zelinski speaking tonight
um
said as well that it's uh
it's not yet fully confirmed
so so um
yeah of course of course uh doing our
everything which is which is very
difficult given the circumstances in the
besieged mario
to get confirmation uh on on the use of
chemical weapons it would be of course
um another heinous war crime
uh
what more can the eu do what are
sanctions enough for now um or do they
need to consider taking uh military
action to support the people of ukraine
just hearing from the deputy defense
minister saying it's not yet safe for
civilians return to return to places
including kiev
i did return to here
[Music]
late last week and
other diplomatic missions
are returning and of course um
one sees awful lot of people
returning to kiev here is home
kiev means jobs
and
shops and restaurants are slowly
slowly opening up
yeah would you advise um
fellow ukrainians to come home yet
this is not for me to advise
this is for the for the ukrainian
authorities
i did return because in diplomacy
most added value comes from the presence
and one needs to be as a diplomat one
needs to be on the ground in kiev
in direct contact with the ukrainian
authorities
okay um thank you sir um for joining us
on the program this morning we do
appreciate it uh do keep well and keep
safe thank you
thank you
meantime back home domestic politics
let's find out uh more about the impact
of rising inflation and the increasing
cost of living in standing by for us in
manchester this morning uh hi inzy
inflation even higher than expected
yeah a 30-year high k and a lot of
people will be looking at that and
thinking
how on earth are we expected to afford
very basic things we know the cost of
living crisis
has been worsening and today it takes
yet another hit this
new announcement today
takes into account the month of a war in
ukraine it takes into account fuel
prices
food prices going up as well and really
paints a bleak picture of the future in
terms of finances for everyday people um
we're in manchester's uh smithfield
market and we've got uh mariella with us
uh here who owns this uh very it's not
too fishy actually a fish stall here
fresh fish doesn't smell well there we
go um mariela just give us your reaction
to hearing the news this morning that
inflation has hit a 30-year high well
i'm not surprised at all it's been
increasing since the beginning of brexit
and we've been we've had whammy with
brexit we've had covered and now we are
suffering this terrible
injustice of the russian war
all our costs since
just pre-brace it have been steadily
rising and i would say that
the import costs on the fish from abroad
at least 25 to 30
we sell a lot of poultry which is based
in this country and penrith our main
poultry supplier and his costs have gone
up because of course they've stopped the
farmers using the red diesel
there's been bird flu the cost of
delivering from penrith to here every
day is costing him another 250 to 350
pound just for the increase in diesel
and so when we talk about the cost of
living crisis people coming here you
know want to buy fish for their business
for personal use and things like what
are people telling you when you're
having to put your prices up as well as
a result we've tried as much as we
possibly can to swallow as much
of that but we just can't it's an
impossibility
um when you're every delivery is costing
you an extra
20
we don't make that we're wholesalers and
the when we retail out we don't put a
massive profit on you know it's 10 it's
15 and these are people that are
struggling these people that can the
reason they're here is because for
between 15 and 20 pounds they can fill
their freezer of good
quality item
and their every time we import this
stuff because it comes across the sea
well the container prices have gone up
by five times so they've gone from three
and a half thousand to fourteen thousand
this is a knock-on situation so they've
got to contend with the the ghastly
electricity the food prices going up
travel going up
what are they supposed to choose do we
eat or do we eat
and it's disgraceful yeah it's a it's a
very tough question for for a lot of
people across the country now maria
thank you so much just painting a
picture there of what it's like for her
as a business but also for the customers
that come and shop here now the bank of
england have also said that the
inflation could increase later this year
to a 40-year high later on this year to
10 now that really would be an even
bleaker picture for many across the
country but today's news already many
will be looking and thinking
whether they do eat or or heat and that
is a big question for many across the
country okay um nc thanks very much
thank you more now on the dining street
parties rao and the fines that have been
handed out to the prime minister and
also to the chancellor and indeed the
prime minister's wife amongst others
so ros altman is standing by for us this
morning to talk about it in more detail
um what would be the honourable thing
this altman for the prime minister to do
well obviously
those kind of decisions are up to the
prime minister and tory mps
but i think
many people around the country are going
to feel very
anxious
to learn that when they were
behaving in accordance with the rules
made by the government that
the government itself
many people at the top and it's not just
the prime minister but so many people in
downing street
seemed to believe
that the rules were optional
and they decided
not to keep them or they didn't think
carefully enough about whether
it was appropriate to do so
and this is just the beginning you know
we have lots of people who seem to have
played fast and loose with rules that
were imposing dreadful hardships
on people around the country i was not
in favor and i'm still not in favor and
hope we never again
have
draconian restrictions on people's
intimate personal lives forbidding them
from seeing family loved ones children
even when
there are heartbreaking situations
this is the first of a number of
uh so-called parties being investigated
and you know
i think it it is shocking
to see
the police
issuing
fines
and but i do however understand
that
in the middle of a war
and with a cost of living crisis
and with so much else happening
around
the country and around the world
that the
urgency of immediate reaction
may
may not be the best
but i'm sure a large number of tory mps
are thinking to themselves
about what their constituents are going
to be feeling and saying
when they see this some people will say
well it doesn't matter you know
i never kept to the rules so that's okay
but most people around the country
certainly everyone i know
was pretty much keeping to the rules and
wouldn't have dreamt
of getting together with
family
or with friends
to celebrate their birthday in in
numbers okay so
let me come back to you baron assaultman
if i may on on one of those points when
you're talking about the fact what we're
looking over and we're looking south and
we're south
east and we're looking at what's
happening as far as ukraine is concerned
uh and there is a war there at the
moment the prime minister needs to focus
on that but you know we did change prime
ministers during the second world war we
did change prime ministers during the
gulf war we've seen uh financial crises
before the question surely has to be
whether the british public see our
present prime minister incumbent in
downing street as an honorable man there
are
elections may elections coming up just
around the corner
well that will be a very interesting
test
um
as to what the public believe
i i believe that this is wrong the prime
minister
is in the middle of further
investigations and i'm hoping that we
will also get the sue grey report
i can't defend
the um
gatherings parties whatever you want to
call them
that were happening
seemingly in a social setting with
alcohol and with
music in some cases
but that does also need to come out you
know we need to hear what what went on
who was there
the fact that it's both the prime
minister and the chancellor who seemed
to have
broken the law
in this way
does create even more of a problem
um and and i think the problem we have
is
within the political establishment
the public are losing
trust and faith
in the decency and the honor
and the integrity
shown by the people who seek to lead our
country
you know
at the last election
we had
i think the most terrible choice
between you know
a leader who was very much in favor of
brexit
and a leader who was
of the opposition
at the time
who was
promoting all sorts of
policies that most of us clearly
couldn't support and indeed when you
look at what's happened in russia you
have to believe
that you know we got the right outcome
this is a very dangerous world but i
believe in truth honesty and integrity
and i also hope
that the
moral fiber of our country
will be restored at the moment i think
there is a question mark
over
the
integrity and the trust that can be
placed in the people at the top
and we have to be able
uh to trust them certainly we've had an
apology that is welcome
certainly i think there has to be a
reckoning in parliament
uh
at the moment parliament's in recess
that is a shame because this needs to be
properly aired and
you know
it is very difficult for
uh the country
to see
that while they have been experiencing
the most awful awful privations you know
when loved ones were dying they couldn't
see them when they wanted to celebrate
marriages they couldn't do so
uh you know
all of these things are quite
uh incredible when you think what we've
done and the impositions per imposed on
the british people
but i do not believe we can have a
situation
where the public
wonders whether this particular law
is one that they should actually keep or
whether
everyone else is going to break it so
they might as well break it too that
cannot be
i'm so sorry
yeah we must leave it there thank you
very much indeed for taking the time to
join us on the programme this morning
very much appreciated thank you thank
you
we've got some breaking news now
concerning cladding and the government
has revealed plans to see the industry
contribute five billion pounds to
address the building's safety scandal in
a victory for leaseholders levelling up
secretary michael gove has agreed a
solution with the housing industry that
will see developers commit a minimum of
2 billion pounds to fix their own
buildings industry will also pay up to a
further 3 billion through an expansion
to the building safety levy under the
new agreement which will become legally
binding more than 35 of the uk's biggest
home builders have pledged to fix all
buildings 11 metres plus that they have
played a role in developing in the last
30 years
now then uh have a look at this when it
comes to partygate
i'm sure that it would ever happen the
guidance was followed and the rules were
followed at all times
all guidance was followed completely
during number ten i can tell you that
the guidelines were followed at all
times this is where i live and to where
i work those were meetings of people at
work talking about work
the smp leader at westminster in
blackfoot is with us now hello to you mr
blackford thank you for joining us on
the program okay it's embarrassing for
the prime minister it's embarrassing for
the chancellor but it's done knife and
they've got other things to worry about
no i mean i wish that were the case but
it's not and i hope that conservative
mps listen to the likes of ross altman
and to dominic grieve that i think speak
about the real threat to
our public life when you've got a prime
minister and you just showed with your
clip there
that blatantly lied to the house of the
commons not just once or twice but
repeatedly
this is the first prime minister that's
been found to break the law
and he's walking away from his
responsibilities he's not accepting
responsibilities i wrote to him
yesterday saying that he should be
recalling parliament we need to be
meeting this week and he should be
coming
to offer his resignation he has
overstepped the mark and you know from
the point of view of process and
parliament
if you willfully mislead parliament then
it's not a question or ifs or buts isn't
the question about any dubai
you must resign
and he cannot simply argue that he
didn't know that these events were
parties good grief
this was partying on an industrial scale
that was taking place at westminster it
wasn't just as he's tried to say any
statement he was breaking the rules no
prime minister you weren't you were
breaking your own laws
and you were
but mr blackford you know we were in the
middle of a global pandemic the prime
minister was and his team were doing
their level best working 24 7 to try and
get as a vaccine to protect us from
covid 19. we were seeing millions of
people dying around the world we were
certainly one of the first in not the
first country in the world to have that
vaccine that was what the prime minister
presided over he might have had a drink
you know he might have celebrated when
it was his birthday he might have had a
drink in the garden to thank staff for
what they were doing
and now he has to deal with a war in
ukraine he was there risking his own
life uh just a couple of days ago and in
addition to that we can see inflation is
at the highest level in decades
come on he just needs to stay in office
and try and get us through this no he
needs to leave office because when
millions of other people were making so
many sacrifices couldn't be with her
loved ones couldn't be with the loved
ones when they were dying
and you had this culture been downing
street of partying let's not forget that
image of the queen
sitting on her own
her husband's funeral and the night
before a party taking place within
downing street they simply don't get it
and he and those around them think that
the rules don't apply to them that they
can do as they please and quite frankly
it isn't good enough there has to be
morality there has to be ethics in
public life and that has to be the set
of circumstances that when you cross the
line as he did
as those around him did 50 people
in his operation have been fined
somewhere along the line
there has to be responsibility some
point along the line he has to put his
hand up and say look i have done wrong i
need to accept that under those
circumstances i have forfeited the right
to govern i forfeited the right to lead
okay but 50 fines um so far there may
well be more that's certainly what we're
being led to believe by the metropolitan
police but i think it was dennis healey
who once said that you don't examine
your entrails in the midst of battle and
quite literally we have a good
relationship via the prime minister
with the ukrainian president now is not
the time even if you feel that he needs
to go now is not the time for that to
happen
it's cross-party unity that we stand
with our friends in ukraine that we
stand with president zarenski of course
we stand with our allies in that as well
we call out for putin for what he is a
warmonger
a war criminal but the idea that we need
the prime minister to do that is just
simply bogus let's not forget that the
united kingdom changed prime minister in
both the first and the second world war
this man is a stain on our democracy we
need to show that united front i and
other opposition leaders work
extensively with ben laws the defense
minister but just reflect on this loki
that the previous prime minister theresa
may anytime she went to a nato summit
would come back and make a statement in
the house of commons this plan that's
saying he's leading the fight against
ukraine went to nato summit two weeks
ago and did not come back to parliament
he doesn't discharge his
responsibilities for him number 10 is a
personal plaything and we've seen over
the course of the last few years
everything that's going on illegally
pro-rolling parliament lying to the
queen the dodgy coving contracts
stuffing his pals that give money to the
tories into the house of lords this man
doesn't understand how he should behave
as prime minister and this insult to the
people of the united kingdom by lying to
parliament repeatedly the first prime
minister that breaks the law quite
simply it has to go there's no lesser
but it has to go okay if it's not about
so let's talk about brexit then should
we for you know whatever your view is on
brexit we are where we are we need the
trade deals in order to get our economy
back up and running again we've seen
what interest rates are doing the prime
minister needs to
straddle the world stage and show that
we are a force to be reckoned with he
doesn't need people bickering with him
because he had a can of beer or whatever
it was for his birthday
it wasn't about a canadian it was about
a culture of partying you know when it
comes to brexit myself and others told
them that we needed to have a proper
trading relationship with the european
union we talked about for us our
compromise with the single market and
the customs union he's now got the
shambles of the northern ireland
protocol that's leading to all sorts of
problems because he did a deal that
quite simply doesn't fit the needs of uk
businesses and uk consumers but he's
responsible for that he created that and
what he needed to do was to make sure
that he worked with others to make sure
that he wasn't going to do untold damage
to the uk economy as he's now doing
nevertheless he is where he is and it
doesn't look as though he's moving
anytime soon because that is up to the
uh conservative backbenchers and they
are decidedly quiet at the moment um if
not him though then whom
well you know this is the tragedy of the
whole thing because it is up to the
conservative mps but they need to do
their job they need to understand that
the public want the prime minister to go
now we should have been doing that this
week i hope that the prime minister
comes to parliament next week there's a
suggestion he might even be away on a
trade trip to india the prime minister
needs to come to the house of commons we
need to have that ability to hold into
account and conservative mps need to
recognize that they have that
responsibility they have the moral
authority to remove this man that's lied
to parliament right to the public broken
the law
they now need to stand up and they need
to accept their own responsibilities
don't run away from
this because at the end of the day if
you do the public will seek the revenge
on someone that can be trusted in public
office and you cannot accept uh for one
second that that was then it was the
middle of a pandemic he was doing his
level best along with his team to try to
keep the country safe and by having a
glass of wine or um a karaoke here and
there if that if indeed the prime
minister was attending that or a beer
and a glass and a piece of cake for his
birthday that lasted less than nine
minutes the only thing that he's had to
find for so far you can't forgive him
for that you can't find it in your heart
to forgive him for that
16 different events i think it was it
took place over a number of months in
downing street it's that culture it's
that that the rules didn't apply to the
prime minister of this team the rules
were for the little people for the rest
of us frankly it was the content
the disregard that showed for the public
and that very important aspect that
people couldn't agree properly couldn't
hug their loved ones and a prime
minister that couldn't care because he
was going to carry on partying